[Music]
because this is what you think about
when watching Batman Bugs Bunny remember
that time bugs was eating people and
Batman solved the case when he found
traces of beta carotene and the bite
wounds Frank Miller was a dark brother
Batman mask of the Red October why would
they put a fucking walkway at the top of
a garage like that and even with the
uprights around it that still needs to
be covered how many drunk people doing
the walk of shame back to their car have
fallen to their deaths
hey good look and I take a good look I
mean Batman who always seems to find the
criminals who use the skylight room to
discuss their illegal I'm not sure why
anyone in Gotham chooses to be a
gangster to make money considering you
could make it very healthy an honest
living
repairing windows I know this is an
exhausting topic but they know who the
Batman is and what he's capable of why
would anyone when given an alternate
option send guys one at a time to fight
him come on man that's clearly not
Batman hell is Batman
all you had to do was run from the
casino penthouse across the walkway to
the parking garage glad you're done with
your epic dump Batman the situation
badly needs you also it seems like a sin
that this exact same stunt look more
realistic in Furious 7 oh by the way I
pressed your tights and put away your
exploding gas balls
well you certainly can't just leave your
exploding gas balls hanging out and when
you have them out Wow wearing wrinkly
tights nothing gets you kicked out of a
movie theater faster gotta hand it to
Bruce he can take a huge splash of wine
to the face and not get any on his
tuxedo it's like all great love stories
begins in a cemetery grieving over your
parents while someone else grieves over
their mom this time who are you talking
to my mother
did he think she was talking to you
Bruce Wayne does not know how to
graveyard etiquette also well it's not
the flashback of the actual death of
Batman's parents thank God
movie still has to have a reminder that
Bruce's parents were killed cliche well
Bruce
here goes holy Sh this flashback which
started with Bruce remembering the time
he fell in love with Andreia Beaumont at
a cemetery is still going but I guess
it's not often that you fall in love and
fight crime for the first time all in
one day who drinks coffee from a mug in
a car and try to keep your eyes open
this time
damn it Jonesy that's not how hanging
onto a truck while it crashes works
should come as no surprise that the
paragraphs on this newspaper have
nothing to do with the headlines or the
pictures but maybe it should since this
is animated and someone chose to write
these incongruent articles it's been
three days since we met and still now
cause Bruce makes a snide remark about
this in a second and he would be
excellent at cinema since but allow me
to pile on Jesus lady
you guys didn't exchange phone numbers
you had no agreement to get in touch
like you must have made all your
boyfriend's track you down before going
on a first date and that's the only way
you know how it's done nice footwork can
you dance too if I had a nickel for
every time me jiu-jitsu in a girlfriend
to the ground ended up with us making
out well I wouldn't have any nickels
damn Alfred
Betty regret putting away Bruce's
exploding gas balls now Jesus that
flashback lasted so long I forgot all
about masks and phantasms I thought I
was watching a cartoon reality show
called Bruce and aundrea heavy petting
Cemetery time mr. Bronski holy Sh this
is exactly like cinemasins team-building
sessions this movie has been 100%
realistic so far getting the details of
vigilante phantasms down to an absolute
teeth so that's why it's so
disappointing that I can somehow see
this guy's eyes and teeth in pitch
darkness I demand and expect more guys
well gentlemen
any ideas the animation budget was not
enough for the team to draw an apple so
they had to settle for some breath spray
and Hart Buckner's voice to show that
this guy's an asshole so the bat signals
kind of dumb right I mean it's there in
the sky for everyone to see and let all
Batman's villains know exactly where
he's gonna be why is there never a
rooftop ambush when that baby gets lit
up Oh for fuck's sake smoothie is 20
minutes in and Bruce has looked at a
painting of his parents which led to a
flashback of him looking at the
tombstone and now his Batman he's
checking the tombstone out again if we
were to construct a pie chart of Bruce
Wayne Batman's activities 50% of his
time is dedicated to mourning his
parents 36 percent to crime and the
other 14% spread out to miscellaneous
activities sorry mom but the whole
world's going to seed how is she there
isn't this an active crime scene
I mean maybe or he could have just heard
you conversing with your dead mother in
the middle of the night which is right
by the Wayne grave site but I guess this
is better than him ripping his mask off
in front of you while you're dressed
like a cat I gotta say I don't
understand anything about the traffic
going on here that doesn't appear to be
any cars or traffic light in front of
the leading car but no one is moving and
what is this tree here you've got a car
on the left a car on the right and one
in the middle that's like room for one
more this is Arthur Reeves one of the
hot young turks from my legal department
that's racist
it's my shirt too big or is that my
flesh crawling your shirt is too big
just doesn't hurt so bad anymore I would
have removed every sin plus all the sins
from the room and The Last Airbender
Bruce wasn't goddamn talking to the
Wayne tombstone here a random homeless
guy would have been more awesome
[Music]
yes we know
brain sadness brooding excitement O'Neal
funding corporation ABS tool and dye
copy stain bendy straw you think you
know everything about me don't you I die
but your bottom I bloody well ought to
sir well you're wrong
meanwhile on my so called Batman life
when Batman built this Batcave why did
he make it so that he has to drive on
this dangerous curve to go out I
couldn't he planned this so they didn't
have a straight shot out of here what if
that curve is all the difference if he
misses saving somebody oh these
flashbacks are about to give me whiplash
an absurd amount bats come out of this
hole too overly symbolise how Bruce
can't have a normal life and probably to
spread sauce but mostly the symbolism
thing left with dad need time damn Draya
really doesn't like to write complete
sentences does she Bruce is upset which
means time to look at the painting of
his parents again how long ago were
these flashbacks alfred looks like he's
in his early 40s here and the movie
showed Bruce and aundrea on a date
looking at a World of Tomorrow exhibit
which is either a 1939 or 1964 New York
World's Fair concept and when we saw
Bruce fighting crime for the first time
we saw this old 30s or 40s tile cop car
and we even saw car phone and Bruce's
rules in one of these flashbacks which
really confuses things for the most part
though the space between the past and
present seems to be a span of 20 to 50
years where Bruce and aundrea haven't
changed the poor Alfred's age 20 to 30
years are we sure with all the bad
imagery they aren't vampires
you gotta love how this cars headlights
maintain two perfect circles on the
ground without illuminating anywhere
else dad saw when in doubt throw a joker
in your Batman movie they didn't call
this mask of the phantasm for nothing
also why does the Joker sound so much
like Chucky and of course Joker lives in
the world of tomorrow exhibit because
this movie can't flashback to one thing
that doesn't get featured later
regardless of how improbable it is often
you're the only one who can take him
down but he really can't right I mean he
hasn't yet in their hundred or so
encounters
does Fame not exist in this world
hmm that's tucking where's your father
now having a clue what a dramatic gas
car I mean maybe in 12 years but I don't
think you'll be very satisfied with it I
can read lips then read them now get out
pretty sure he doesn't have to read them
he can hear him
that's exit to Eden not know what
reading lips means how's the glass on
the floor still intact considering we
just heard it shatter a few seconds ago
[Music]
why wouldn't the explosion just happen
immediately after phantasm pulled off
the blanket or walked in the house did
he just land on I mean yes it's a Ledge
but it looks like he landed on the very
edge of it and the animation is such
that it looks like he landed on the side
of the building then just jumped off
Batman survives this Batman shoots the
grappling hook at the helicopter and
immediately springs towards it but why
aren't wha it's just a barrier with
Batman's cape on it he fooled them but
tell me something how the fuck did he
pull off his cape and put it around that
wooden barrier without anyone seeing it
he'd also need an extra set of hands to
pull the dog and God help me if you say
because he's Batman because this
motherfucker should have escaped already
if that's the case how the hell did
Andre I know Bruce would be traced to
this exact alleyway and God help me if
you say because she's Batman because
jeez even this guy's sweat is angry
Batman flash of the back TASM this time
tomorrow
on my mother's grave can we just stop
talking about graves money for our 24
hours or blah blah blah cliche I'm sure
they would have wanted you to be happy
sir no they wanted Bruce to constantly
look at their paintings in grave site
Alfred no yes this seems like valid
proof this is Joker calling Batman
telling him he's gonna die and once
again I have to wonder why even bother
giving him a warning but if you sight
the Lego Batman movie is your source for
answering this you need to give me 50
pushups grocery bags contain at least
one French baguette cliche well under as
flashback ends right as this guy starts
eating an apple it is at least implied
that he is an asshole what do you say
feeling the old electricity tonight
Joker has definitely that robot very
cute but I can blow smoke too
some of that corrosive material had to
hit her clothing and she touches it with
her other hand which is only protected
by a glove aundrea has been kicking
everyone's ass easily up until the joker
and has to resort to an IAM in the nuts
cliche movie it's just not gonna explain
this bullshit probably for the best but
yeah what a bunch of bull you see if
you're going to suck someone into a fan
this is why you don't put the fan behind
a bunch of death escaping flagpoles
aundrea is definitely almost sucked into
the fan here but because of some sort of
editing / magic trick she's nowhere near
the fan when Batman jumps to save her
your father's dead isn't he you came
into town early to get Chucky saw so you
could shift the blame to your father if
you had to how would this even hold up
someone would eventually figure out
Beaumont senior was dead if it wasn't
already known in whatever place they
reside it or maybe she's got him rocking
in the chair in the upstairs bedroom
mrs. Bates style which would have been a
much better ending I mean damn it this
is a real vanishing act then why didn't
she do that when she was getting sucked
into the fan nice Warner Brothers that's
some good branding mayor take a sin you
bastards
I feel like this movie was an early
attempt at adapting The Killing Joke
that's basically the same setup with
Batman and Joker fighting and what might
as well be the remains of a carnival
here it's just the remains of a World's
Fair silver Joker no Joker surfer silver
jerk will you stop telling Batman
everything good god I love the Mark
Hamill voice work this character can't
keep his goddamn mouth shut
also I think it's weird how this became
a joker story in the end yeah it makes
sense that he's in it but he was
basically dragged into it by one of the
old mob guys he didn't put the plot
elements into motion at all but yet here
we are
he's the movie's climactic final battle
this movie only someone had anything to
do with the phantasm Batman is going to
somehow run up this rocket and catch
Joker and all I've got to say is the
last season the game of Thrones has been
wicked disappointing aundrea you've got
to get out of here the place is wired to
explode there was so much pause in that
delivery I think Kevin Conroy might have
gone deep inside for his inner Shatner
also why is there always a fucking place
wired to explode I'm not sure there's
enough explosive material in existence
to cover all these action in comic book
movies
wait what had it Andre I do that he's
not wearing any of her doodads and she's
not an actual sorceress that is the
cleanest and clearest sewer water I have
ever seen
they must diamonds in Gotham I couldn't
save her Alfred what makes you so sure
she died she disappeared in smoke like
she always did as Queen used to say it's
a kind of magic but you're Batman so I
don't know why you don't know this hey
Bruce just wanted you to know I'm alive
but we can't be together because
something something darkness something
something damaged but more importantly I
store Joker in a secure place that you
can only find if you solve a series of
clues each of them with increasing
difficulty as you move through the game
Aquaman
glad you could make it I brought some
shrimp well now they can call me fat man
those fools and spooky fools will
terrify your dreams you can't escape
this never find your precious blunt game
did you have night what's meant by you
we can claim the throne of Eternia but
at least man-at-arms won't be a problem
anymore but on the plus side I knocked
over the Sun sphere ever dance with the
devil in the pale wine I died but you're
bluffing no fair the only one in this
room controlled by his parents is you